i bet your money when you were younger
bro you were some hot [ __ ] huh me
yeah scott randolph i still am hot [ __ ]
no but you thickened and you're a little
older yeah still good still legit like
if you were in the grocery store we
wouldn't take you off the [ __ ]
shelves it's still like i'm a staple
exactly bro yeah but i'm like cheerios
but you were [ __ ] more [ __ ]
20 years ago
20 15 five
yeah i mean dude if we're really gonna
attack scott randolph like i'm not
attacking him i'm giving him compliments
right
of the past if i was a food dude like i
wouldn't be on the shelving you'd have
to ask the person that works there and
they have to go in the back to get me
do you mean
it's kind of a specialty this compliment
is like if i'm going through the tsa at
the airport and the guy says oh man like
where you've been dude i haven't seen
you in anything forever
and i'm like dude i'm very active just
on like youtube i know i [ __ ] hate it
and because we're alcoholics yeah you're
recovering we said we're sensitive to
that right well he is too so i started
thinking about it like on the plane like
if that happened to me at the lax i'd be
on the plane thinking about it but is
that not the backhanded compliment that
you just gave scott
i'm like i'm a model and you're like
what a hand model
no
the model citizen stop bro
bro i like that no what i was doing is
is like you know
like you remind me of a josh brolin type
yeah now or then no so josh brolin now
or sicario that's what i'm saying right
so i'm saying when he was in goonies he
was too young
how about thrashing
thrashing he was in a movie called
thrashing how old was he then oh my god
perfect
right
if i was in bed with them i'd feel this
scruff against my belly you know this
facial scrub against my belly like
scraping my [ __ ] right you're like yeah
go ahead go ahead no no carney
i love you bro thanks dude because you
have like a midwestern skateboarding
type of i'm from the midwest and do you
skateboard uh i used to but i broke my
whisper my wrist and i stopped yeah i
get that yeah yeah skateboarding anyway
i wasn't hit on you bro no it's all good
it's just we
don't remember playing ping pong at
steve's house back in the day oh that's
right
i played ping pong yeah did i win no but
you're better than i am but you for sure
lost dude i remember that night very
very well i asked you bobby to come over
and give me notes on my
comedy act like five days before taping
the special that was ridiculous with uh
ian edwards
why did you
get us over here
like five days before taping the special
i know it was just like it's almost too
late yeah that's what it felt you were
like we can give you notes but did you
do that in high school did you like
crazy
if you had a test that night like
midnight you started cramming
i'm at gas yeah oh i never went to
school really myself
i was a really bad student yeah yeah
where'd you grow up san diego bro oh
really yeah where you from bro pasadena
[ __ ] yeah dude
do you um
dude you know my brother what's your
brother's name steven randolph and
chelsea
wait stephen randolph your brother yeah
your real brother uh-huh oh that's right
yeah because stephen yeah that's right
you are him
yeah yeah yeah and now i get that i get
it
i know the vibe maybe that's the
connection
there's a connection there you also look
like him like by his vibe right here's
the thing stephen randolph is scott's
older brother and would like to
physically abuse him like dramatically
abuse jesus
because
because he was such hot [ __ ] like like
steven randolph was so not as attractive
as scott scott got all the attention and
so steven randolph took it out on him
physically violently yeah i get that
because steven randolph um he's a
physically violent guy
he's like a standard white
his face he's like you know he works
like he looks like he works at
enterprise
rental or you know
or like he's the manager at home depot
right you have more of a like you know
70s porn vibe
josh brolin josh yeah yeah yeah i like
that
magnum pi vibe dude yeah you like that
yeah i don't it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude